bonjour merci d'être avec nous pour un
nouveau numéro de dimanche en politique
la semaine dernière nous nous sommes
penchés sur la gauche
et cette semaine c'est la primaire de la
droite qui va nous intéresser la droite
qui va désigner les 20 et 27 novembre
son candidat ou sa candidate à
l'élection présidentielle cette
candidature en lice et sur ce plateau
les représentants des quatre premières
pour l'instant d'après les sondages à la
houppe r bonjour bonjour vous êtes
sénateur de côte-d'or et vous soutenez
nicolas sarkozy c'est l'attrait martin
président du grand chalon vous êtes le
coordinateur de la campagne d'alain
juppé dans votre département la
saône-et-loire bonjour mon chéri riktigt
gentil conseiller régional de l'yonne
vous soutenez bruno le maire donc j'ai
bon jour et fabienne cardo bonjour vous
êtes adjointe au maire de corbigny dans
la nièvre vous coordonnez la campagne de
françois fillon dans votre département
et vous faites partie de l'équipe de
campagne nationale de françois fillon et
si l'on rajoute ont donc que sont aussi
en lice pour cette primaire jean
françois copé nathalie kosciusko morizet
et jean frédéric poisson ce qui fait
donc sept candidats et candidates avant
de parler des candidats et des
programmes on va quand même se pencher
avec vous sur le l'idée même de la
primaire avec un peu d'humour j'avais
écrit pour commencer des primaires à
droite on pourrait dire cherchez
l'intrus
ça ne fait pas partie de l'adn de la
droite
est-ce qui a pas une forme de danger
alain houpert doucement c'est dans cette
opération
bon il est vrai que c'est pas dans nos
gènes nous faisons ici partis tous les
quatre de ce nouveau parti qui s'appelle
les républicains une famille où il ya
des mouvements on a toujours eu
l'habitude de publicité en interne un
chef qui va qui va se battre avec le
risque au premier tour d'avoir quelqu'un
proche de nos familles pour le faire
basculer
donc ça c'est une initiative un peu de
la gauche mais les temps ont changé le
président notre président nicolas
sarkozy a été battu en 2012
donc nous allons être dans un euro vers
un renouvellement de deux majorités
présidentielles je pense qu'il va y
avoir une alternance et il est normal
que les républicains c'est un parti
moderne parti moderne ça parti
républicain et nous nous sommes là tous
en famille en ami qui ré parce qu'on se
connaît tous et on est là pour débattre
soutiens quelqu'un mais soutenir
quelqu'un veut pas dire qu'on est contre
les autres c'est dangereux c'est une
bonne idée
notre point de vue la prière elle
constitutionnel ou faux donc voilà je
pense que c'est comme on dit mais
superbe parce que plus de chef naturel
en fait qui qui se dégage puisque il est
normal que d'anciens terrains la
république se représente mais comme il a
été battu nous n'avons plus de chef
naturel et puis je crois aussi qu'il ya
une démocratisation de la vie publique
qui fait que chacun a envie et bien de
s'exprimer de prendre position il a ça
permet finalement à chaque citoyen parce
qu'on ne sait pas exactement qui va
voter à la primaire
à chaque citoyen de choisir le candidat
de la droite est très certainement le
prochain président la république et les
gentils vous avez vécu dans l'yonne le
duel copé fillon à tout le monde l'avait
vécu à droite dans l'yonne c'est avaient
été particulièrement tendus
quelque part dans votre tête vous avez
sept trains que ça se renouvelle que les
règles soient difficilement respectée et
qu'il y ait des débordements ça fait
partie le risque de l'exercice ou pas
alors ça peut faire partie du risque de
l'exercice mais je n'ai vraiment aucune
printemps à ce niveau là effectivement
les primaires pour moi c'est vraiment un
moment important dans la vie politique
parce que notre société évolue et la
politique c'est le moment de débattre et
donc les primaires nous permettent de
débattre
nous avons une plateforme commune au
niveau des républicains et après
quelques différences dont on va parler
tout à l'heure et c'est un moment
important pendant 2 3 mois nous allons
débattre nous allons affiner le projet
que portera notre candidat qui sera
désigné le 27 novembre avec des risques
ou pas sébastien martin
que tout le monde se respecte tout le
monde se respecte pas ou que dans une
deuxième campagne quelle qu'elle soit il
ya toujours un peu des coupes guillaume
larrivé que j'avais au téléphone il ya
quelques jours disait vous les
journalistes vous adorez la primaire
mais nous il faut qu'on fasse très
attention
bien sûr il faut toujours faire
attention parce que dans une campagne
est toujours un peu de testostérone
ça fait partie de la vie politique mais
je crois que l'essentiel c'est d'agir
sous la conduite plutôt de la raison
donc il faut pour cela que chacun arrive
avec des propositions un projet
construit etc etc
c'était pas dans notre tradition que
d'aller vers des primaires
maintenant c'est un fait qui est acté ça
a été dit et pas de candidat naturel à
partir du moment où l'élection à la
présidence de l'ump avait pas déterminer
un choix aussi net que par le passé je
me souviens d'élections où les
présidents notre famille politique était
élu plus de 80% des voix donc on va dire
et pas de débat derrière
aujourd'hui il ya un débat qui permettra
de rassembler largement et c'est comme
ça qu'on peut gagner il n'y a pas
d'autre méthode sur l'exercice
démocratique
un certain nombre de
constitutionnalistes ont remarqué que la
primaire c'est pas forcément si
démocratique que ça parce que les gens
qui vont voter sont pas forcément qu'ils
vont voter à la primaire sont pas
forcément représentatif de l'électorat
de l'élection ensuite en particulier on
sait à peu près des instituts de sondage
laisse entendre que globalement les gens
qui vont voter à votre primaires sont
des gens plus âgés que la moyenne
nationale plus aisé que la moyenne
nationale
est ce qu'il y à pas par rapport à cet
électorat l'obligation d'une forme de
surenchère ou d'aller chercher avec un
certain nombre d'arguments un électorat
particulier là encore il faut parler à
tout le monde et ça vaut pas là tout le
monde parle aux jeunes il faut par les
personnes âgées peu par le travailleur
pour parler à ceux qui sont qui n'ont
pas la chance d'avoir un travail et
c'est les difficultés de de ce travail
sans tomber dans le populisme c'est à
dire on entend beaucoup de choses on
entend des déformations de propos de
certains
candidat à la primaire il est vrai que
ces pc pas le panel électorale qu'on va
avoir au moins deux mois de mai ça va
être un gros projet neige en plus de 60
ans faut peut-être labourer un sillon
qui n'est pas le signe d'une élection je
sais pas s'il faut se poser la question
sous cet angle là de toute façon partir
du moment où on a accepté le principe de
la primaire il faut accepter que bien
évidemment 100 % de la population va pas
se déplacer que je vais dire mais pour
toute élection il ya une part de
participation et une part d'abstention
c'est d'ailleurs un des vrais sujets je
pense de l'élection présidentielle
demain ceux de se poser la question de
savoir pourquoi 50 % quasiment des gens
ne votent pas ou ne sont pas allés voter
par exemple lors des dernières élections
régionales c'est aussi à ces personnes
là qu'il faut répondre qu'ils sont
désespérés par les politiques et
peut-être que la primaire est un moyen
de les ramener vers la politique en
faisant l'avocat du diable et riktigt
gentil fabienne cardo tout le monde a
dit dès la primaire de la gauche un
super exercice au final ça débouche sur
un quinquennat la plus que compliquée
voire même manqué pour un certain nombre
d'observateurs donc se font aussi
beaucoup d'excès première fois que c'est
la droite en fait un qui fait une
primaire et finalement on voit bien dans
tous les articles politiques et les
sondages que aucun observateur ne sait
vraiment qui va venir voter et suivant
qu'il ya un million deux millions quatre
millions de personnes qui viennent voter
l'exercice va être très très différents
moi ce que je dis pas ce que françois
fillon il a vraiment voulu cette
primaire c'est une nouveauté mais venez
voter
voilà un premier prenait le pouvoir
venez voter à c'est tout le monde peut
s'exprimer
les femmes les hommes les jeunes des
anciens venez voter venez voter parce
que il ya la tentation de l'extrême
comme une nouveauté
faites attention à la nouveauté inconnue
même si je pense le constat du front
national est pertinent je pense que son
programme est un danger pour nous tous
donc venez voter
venez voter sur un projet je veux leur
dire venez voter
il ya qu une carte qui est indispensable
c'est la carte d'identité
enfin la carte d'adhérent un parti mais
juste une carte d'identité suffit
je vois que vous avez préparé votre
argument père bruno le maire aussi ils
voulaient les primaires enfin ça vous
semble
quelque chose de central oui moi tout à
fait je suis très favorable aux
primaires et par rapport à ce que vous
vous disiez tout à l'heure sur les
primaires de la gauche si on se remet
dans le contexte en 2012
il y avait quand même des différences
vraiment très très importante entre les
différents participants à la primaire de
la gauche avec des gens qui étaient
vraiment à la gauche de la gauche
et après en fait ils se sont retrouvés
sur un plus petit dénominateur commun
est ce qui a débouché sur le quinquennat
catastrophique que l'on traverse en ce
moment s'est présentée de m'amener à la
suite parce que vous êtes en train de
laisser penser qu'il y aurait pas
différence très très forte entre
candidats de la primaire de la droite
si on en vient au programme on peut
quand même aussi se poser des questions
et même moi j'ai envie d'être avocate et
en grèce que c'est vraiment la peine de
parler de programme
est-ce que vos champions sont pas
surtout en train d'essayer de fabriquer
de l'image la personnalité parce que ce
qui fait voter les gens dans une
primaire en particulier a droit qu est
ce que ça va pas être l'image côté
dynamique pour l'un la fermeté de
nicolas sarkozy le côté rassembleur de
d'alain juppé le côté rigoureux françois
fillon est ce que c'est ça qui se passe
en ce moment je ne suis pas j'en suis
pas du tout convaincu
ou alors on pas encore du principe que
l'on d'affaires de l'élection
présidentielle finalement essayé de se
faufiler dans un trou de souris et
d'être juste devant marine le pen ou pas
trop trop loin derrière et puis faire un
pari pour le deuxième il a déclaré au
monde samedi je suis le seul qui peut
arriver au premier tour devant marine le
pen dont il est le seul qui peut arriver
au premier tour devant marine le pen
parce qu'il a un programme sur le fond
qui a été travaillé et qui est un
programme qui rassemble et ensuite parce
que je pense qu'il a fait ce pari
peut-être un peu audacieux que de
travailler sur le sérieux des
propositions et pas forcément sur leur
forme mais plus sur le faut donc à
partir de là
effectivement c'est aussi une position
qui peut séduire une position pardon qui
peut séduire une majorité de français je
pense et je le coin allons faire nicolas
sarkozy est en train de faire quoi dans
cette primaire
en lançant un certain nombre de bombes
alors on en avait l'habitude pendant la
campagne de 2012 mais beaucoup parler
les ancêtres gaulois n'a beaucoup parler
du réchauffement climatique et de la
nonne influence de des hommes là dedans
est ce que il veut parler un électorat à
nicolas sarkozy ou est ce que il s est
surpassé tous ses autres concurrents
pour des gens de gauche plus à gauche
que lui pour récupérer le vrai électorat
de la droite il parle pas les autres peu
d autres un petit peu quand même
quelques phrases je n'y connais c'est
quelqu'un il faut les côtés sur le fond
c'est quelqu'un qui a des aspérités qui
n'est pas lisse et si on lui enlevait
les aspérités ça serait pas nicolas
sarkozy
nicolas sarkozy sait c'est chez un homme
d'état et les gens les citoyens français
à la primaire vont choisir pas un homme
politique on choisir un homme d'état
jeudi par un journaliste grenelle de
l'environnement et qui dit le
réchauffement climatique non pas du fait
de l'homme
non il a dit le réchauffement climatique
n'est pas dû qu'à l'activité économique
humaine il est dû aussi à la
surpopulation on va passer en 2100 à
11,5 milliards d'habitants et dans le
dans les rassemblements de paris dans la
cap 21
eh bien on a peu parlé du problème
démographique ça pour nous faire un
cours de démographie mondiale
elle est entre nous il cherche quelque
chose ma question était cher charles et
se positionner par rapport aux autres et
bien sûr que pas bien car dos avec
jantes et fera car vous avez vous donné
l'environnement si important
il ya eu plein de choses les politiques
environnement lumineux mais rigolo et le
histoire des gaulois ou cvc d'identité
nationale et on va devenir aussi gros
quand il est en france c'est pas le
dernier venu qui impose aux autres sa
loi et quand quelqu'un vient en france
quand quelqu'un choisit d'être français
ils essayent de connaître l'histoire des
français et les gaulois les gaulois
c'est quoi les gaulois c'est c'est un
ensemble de peuples qui se sont réunis
et puis ensuite quand les gaulois ont
perdu en 52 avant jésus-christ prêt
d'ici à alenya on a eu la pax romana
pendant des années donc vous ne me
répondez à la question que vous posez
alors cérémonie qui va essayer de
répondre à la question est ce que et
dans les ars cosy et s'est tranformé
bruno le gras les autres en candidat le
plus à gauche par rapport à un électorat
historique de la droite non moi je ne le
pense pas parce que en fait chaque
candidat aux primaires est là pour
présenter son projet très clairement on
n'est pas là pour réagir à ce que va
dire nicolas sarkozy alain juppé
françois fillon
je pense que l'important c'est de venir
devant les français de leur dire là la
nation que nous voulons à l'avenir le
projet que nous avons pour la france
nous avec bruno le maire on veut une
société plus juste
on veut une société où les français qui
travaillent peuvent vivre de leur
travail
on veut une une société où les plus
démunis soient aidés mais parce qu'ils
en ont vraiment besoin
et puis nous avons beaucoup d'autres
thèmes de campagne que nous mettons il
pas en avant mille pages effectivement
et ses 1000 pages en fait c'est le fruit
de quatre ans sur le terrain et de
commentaires de discussions avec des
français et c'est vrai que ça et on
arrive avec un projet de 1000 pages mais
un projet qui est très détaillé qui est
chiffrée et bruno le maire et en france
tous les jours et il participe à des
réunions il explique son projet et je
pense que c'est ça ce que les français
attendent c'est pas la guerre des
petites phrases c'est pas l'image c'est
surtout avoir du fond parce qu'on est en
2010 est on est à un moment crucial
à mon avis dans la vie politique
française
il faut dire les choses et surtout il
faudra faire ce que l'on léhady et ses
pieds dans notre programme fabien cardo
françois fillon lui il a envoyé sa bombe
aussi mais ça bond c'était qu'ils
imaginent le général de gaulle mis en
examen si vous voulez nous faire
polémique
non mais j'essaie aussi de montrer qu'il
ya des différences parce que vous avez
commencé en disant on est tous copains
on sait très bien que d'hab offrons 10
et on en sera d'accord je feins tous les
quatre qu'on partage
d'abord des valeurs communes on a la
même vision de la vie on a la même
vision de la société
on partage des valeurs qui sont des
valeurs de la liberté
les valeurs du travail et valeurs de la
famille et après avis différent c'est
vrai alors françois fillon françois
fillon c'est un homme d'état aussi mais
ça ça chacun le sait il a été premier
ministre de la france
oui c'est vrai françois fillon c'est un
homme de vertu
un homme d'intégrité et je ne porte
aucun jugement sur les autres je met en
relief mon champion mais moi je suis pas
une femme politique moi je supporte pas
rôdés société sils un banc dans la
campagne de construction
moi je suis une femme d'entreprise suis
pas sur le terrain moi je suis du
terrain et en fait ce qui distingue de
françois fillon c'est son équipe ou de
la moitié des gens justement ne sont pas
du métier politique mais sont du métier
réel de la vie quotidienne
maintenant ils essaient tous en
solitaire on parle plus grand nombre par
le congrès 84 parlementaire et on en est
raciale
j'en cherchais je ne le nie pas vous
voyez il ya des gens des et du cloud
comme un droit mais c'est le chef de
notre parti
c'est bien naturel et je crois voilà ce
qui est ce qui distingue de françois
fillon et son équipe par le projet on a
pas mille pages nous on en a juste 100
ans mais bon 50 mo vous verrez on en
reparlera mais c'est surtout ce qu'il ya
derrière lui tout un collectif
il ya derrière lui tout était donc sur
intégrité et leur intégrité vous
répondez pas dans son intégrité je vous
dis voilà c'est un homme qui a des
vertus et notamment il a la vertu de
dire ce qu'il va faire c'est à dire que
dès le lendemain de la primaire
il dira les 15 ministres qui
l'accompagneront s'il est élu et il dira
précisément ce qui fait dans les 100
premiers jours on sait pas c'est martin
qui attendait patiemment son tour par
rapport à l'épisode des gaulois alain
juppé a répondu en fait en disant on va
pas parler de gaulois des temps qu'on
prenne de la hauteur dans ce dans ce
débat ils essaient quoi lui laisser de
se placer ailleurs il essaie de ne pas
parler aux électeurs de la primaire mais
déjà aux français la question d'identité
elle est importante mais après il ya un
peu plus d'an manière heureuse de
manière de voir les choses soient en se
tournant vers le passé en se disant
c'était mieux avant ou bien en se disant
lui d'identité peut aussi servir à se
projeter vers l'avenir mais en même
temps cette question on ne peut pas ne
pas la liées aux problématiques
économiques à dire comment est ce qu'on
peut être heureux et fier d'être
français dans un pays qui tourne en
permanence autour de 10% de chômage qui
est une machine à créer du désespoir en
main lavera pas de l'idée que ça irait
un petit peu mieux nos ce pays c'est
vrai un peu plus de boulot pour les gens
et je pense que du coup les gens
seraient un peu plus heureux et fiers
d'adhérer à la nation française si on
avait réglé aussi un certain nombre de
problèmes économiques et sociaux et donc
c'est pour ça qu'on doit aller vers un
projet d'identité heureuse parce que les
gens sont plus heureux si on règle un
certain nombre de ce2 de problèmes qui
sont posés notre pays aujourd'hui alors
voulu répondre encore c'est l'opposé de
sarkozy l'a attaqué très fort l'identité
heureuse de lui parce que c'est vrai que
les français sont pas heureux de devoir
qu'en france on gagne moins qu'en
allemagne sont pas heureux de voir des
gens qui veulent imposer les minorités
qui veulent imposer aux autres leur
façon de vie et un autre collègue là à
parler du du général de gaulle et dire
que que général de gaulle ne serait pas
mis en examen mais c'étaient les trente
glorieuses et le les temps ont changé je
pense que le général de gaulle aura été
comme tout le monde
attaqué par la justice parce que il ya
eu des pardons chez général de gauche je
suis gaulliste et cie bolide si de
gaulle n'était pas là je ne serais pas
là parce que mon père a passé trois ans
dans un camp de concentration je suis
profondément gaulliste mais je pense que
le général de gaulle a eu des pardons
mois il ya eu des airs qui il ya eu
beaucoup de choses là il
l'algérie je pense que il y aura eu des
juges qui l'aurait mis en examen aussi
qui aurait contesté cette politique
donc c'est un autre temps nous sommes
2013 nous sommes en 2007 nous sommes
actuellement aujourd'hui ici et
maintenant
ne parlons plus du passé le point
central c'était un candidat a la
préférence de la présidentielle mis en
examen est condamnée donc on va pas non
plus les gens vont dire plus on va
avancer sur un sol en fait on parle
d'identité d'identité heureusement
moelleux le mot me gêne parce que pour
moi l'identité sébastien assorti de
couleur sa carte d'identité
c'est quoi l'identité c'est un nom c'est
un prénom c'est une taille et la couleur
des yeux
moi je parlerai plus de culture parce
que je trouve que l'identité c'est quand
même assez réducteur ce que nous avons
en commun c'est la culture française
c'est une culture que l'on a acquis au
fil des siècles et c'est une culture
avec des personnes qui viennent de
différents horizons
on a des rois de france qui sont mariés
avec et des reines espagnol autrichienne
donc c'est quelque chose de beaucoup
plus complexe de beaucoup et c'est
autour de cette culture que l'on doit ce
se retrouver parce que je trouve que le
mot identité est vraiment réducteur par
rapport à la primaire moi j'ai une
question à ses centrales à vous poser on
lit dans certains programmes des envies
des projets de retour sur un certain
nombre de mesures par exemple
l'abrogation de la réforme du collège je
pense pour bruno le maire par exemple et
en fait ça peut nous amener à une
question qui à laquelle vous pourriez
répondre tous les quatre qui et quand on
a un programme pour une primaire et pour
revenir au pouvoir quand vous voulez le
faire et ce qu'on doit être dans le
revient en arrière on annule un certain
nombre de mesures qui ont été prises
dans le quinquennat en cours ou est ce
qu on est obligé d'essayer de trouver
des réformes
réel des propositions nouvelles il faut
est ce que quand on parle à la droite il
faut faire du nouveau où il faut
proposer deux cas c'est le cas a été
réformée avant il ya des choses qui sont
des erreurs des erreurs il faut les
réparer je veux dire par exemple la
question du tiers payant généralisé
aujourd'hui qui est en train de faire un
mal fou à notre système de santé
c'est une erreur sur laquelle il faut
bien évidemment revenir mais après la
question c'est par la france de 2007 de
2012 2014 c'est la france de 2010 est
qui nous intéresse il faut bien apporter
des solutions aux problématiques de la
france de 2010 est avec des solutions de
2017 et en même temps les sujets
fondamentaux
r moi depuis que je suis née je suis né
en 1977 j'entends parler depuis depuis
ma naissance
mais j'ai pas entendu tout de suite de
la problématique du chômage de masse 1
quand ça va mal on est à 12 % et quand
ça va bien on a 8 % quand le plein
emploi devrait être autour de 5 ou 6 %
c'est quand même ça le vrai sujet depuis
30 ans c'est quand même ça bon alors à
partir de là tout le monde sait les
réformes structurelles qu'il faut mener
sujet s'il sera difficile pour la droite
puisque vous me parlez de sur les trente
ans passés et une vos idées ont déjà été
en application un certain nombre de fois
donc voilà pour un euro les gens
attendent un changement un changement
radical mais on va pas faire comme le
président actuel qui a effacé tout ce
qu'a fait nicolas sarkozy
c'est à dire que on prend les français
pour des imbéciles
c'est à dire que l'on change tout on
change tout parce que c'est un homme
qu'il a fait on va changer
comme vous l'avez dit on va changer ce
qui ne marche pas ce qui ne marche pas
ce sont la réforme des rythmes scolaires
qui les enfants sont épuisés les
enseignants n'en peuvent plus il ya des
réformes idiote qu'il faut changer la
carte du scolaire du collège new rose
évident de nouveaux sais quoi parce que
revenir en arrière
non c'est pas revenir en arrière c'est
changer ce qui ne marche pas et puis
élaguer élaguer les français n'en
peuvent plus les entreprises il faut
élaguer tout ce qui est un frein à
l'investissement et à l'engagement des
entreprises à l'engagement citoyen il
faut que
il faut remonter ce pouvoir d'achat le
français est la classe moyenne est
assassiné par les charges les
entreprises sont assassinés par les
normes
j'ai défendu récemment dans une autre
chaîne à public sénat le président
sarkozy quand il a parlé de
l'environnement où ils voulaient
pondérer le principe de précaution par
un principe de responsabilité parce que
ce principe de précaution il interdit
tout actuellement si félix hoffman a
réinventé l'aspirine bayer ne pourrait
même pas la commercialiser
c'est grave fabio carbo est ce qu il m
il faut il faudrait simplifier et il
faudrait démocratiser c'est vraiment
simple on a comme objectif donc
simplifier ces mets moins de normes
d'honneur vous porter les couleurs de
l'ancien premier ministre quand même
excusez moi mais donc ça veut dire quoi
il a fait son il a fait sa révolution il
fera plus comme il l'a fait pendant 5
ans ministre
vous savez que le premier ministre est
un fidèle serviteur du président de la
république je crois justement françois
fillon resté les cinq ans a servi avec
une grande loyauté à nicolas sarkozy et
on nous étions tous derrière nicolas
sarkozy et des choses qui aurait dû être
fait nicolas l'a dit lui-même d'ailleurs
on aurait dû faire plus plus vite sur
les 35 heures sur d'autres choses mais
je crois que là il ya eu un emballement
et je pense à nos agriculteurs aussi
important bourgogne où la chance à tous
nos patrons de pme mais je pense aussi
aux commerçants et aux artisans dont
l'activité se développe mais qui ne
peuvent pas recruter donc vraiment
simplifié jeu pour apprendre tout un tas
d'autres exemples mais je pense que
héritons prendre un et puis et puis
démocratiser et puis démocratiser c'est
ça l'idée que des gens de la société
civile puissent être ministre que les
gens compétents puissent venir aux
responsabilités c'est ça l'idée du
référendum c'est ça l'idée d'un
programme bâti avec des milliers
de gens qui réfléchissent et qu'ils
proposent et qui aboutit à quelque chose
de celle que j'étais l'avocat du diable
en vous disant mais tout le monde dit ça
tout le monde écoute les français tout
le monde tient compte de leurs
revendications et ça dure depuis le
début de la vème république il faut
avoir un projet il faut regarder vers
l'avenir on n'est pas là pour regarder
derrière
même si on a nos racines et c'est très
important il ya des sujets qui sont très
importants aujourd'hui on parlait de
pouvoir d'achat
et là on a des différences sur ce que
l'on propose par exemple sur la baisse
des impôts ou la baisse des charges
bruno le maire propose la baisse de la
csg parce que ça va toucher beaucoup
plus de monde que la baisse des impôts
puisque on a à peu près un français sur
deux qui payent des impôts alors que la
csg concerne les salariés les retraités
donc avec cette proposition là nous
redonnons du pouvoir d'achat donc il y a
des idées qui sont importantes qui sont
défendues par les candidats aux
primaires il y a des différences nous
proposons également une exonération des
charges pour les petites entreprises qui
vont recruter quelqu'un sur la fin de
l'année 2010 est une exonération des
charges pendant un an donc ça c'est du
concret c'est pour relancer l'activité
et c'est ça ce qu'attendent les français
c'est pas des questions d'image des
belles paroles
il leur faut un projet est un projet que
l'on peut mettre en place rapidement
avec des priorités parce qu'on fera pas
tout il reste deux minutes de mission
c'est très court la joie dans vos yeux
que vous auriez voulu trois fois plus
juste en deux minutes juste il faut que
vous nous disiez ce qui va se passer
après est-ce que les touffes autant que
vous êtes vous vous rangerez derrière
celui qui gagnera la primaire sébastien
martins si nicolas sarkozy qui gagnent
et juppéiste dans un bel élan
c'est l'engagement qui a été pris par
chacun des candidats qui est à partir du
moment où on participe à la primaire on
en accepte les règles et les règles de
la primaire c'est celui qui sort
vainqueur est soutenu par ceux qui ne
sont pas sortis vainqueurs de la
compétition donc les règles elles sont
bonnes quand on gagne quand on perd
c'est comme start 1
dans une famille politique alors on peut
enfin les français toutes façons les le
candidat qui va gagner nous sommes nous
sommes le rpr du sommet républicain et
un chef de meute
on suit en avant la musique les français
ils veulent un projet mais ils veulent
surtout qu'on change de politique on
change de logiciel positif j'ai parlé
tout à l'heure de l'identité et des cars
disait je pense donc je suis moi je
dirais plutôt je pense donc tuer les
français veulent un président qui les
écoute et nous allons eu pendant cinq
ans un président qui avait des idées et
qui les imposent est je pense que
nicolas sarkozy va gagner des prières et
nos trois collègues vont se réunir
derrière je vous trouve juste comprends
leur dire quand même s'il nous reste 40
secondes
oui si il y à une règle du jeu très
clair celui qui gagnera le 27 septembre
ce sera notre candidat et on le
soutiendra pour qu'il devienne président
de la république romaine cardo je le
disais nous sommes de la même famille
les mêmes valeurs dont bien sûr nous
serons unis mais y aura un dialogue
entre les entre les sept candidats est
une évolution du projet et je veux
vraiment que le dernier mot soit votée
venez venez voter à la primaire c'est ça
les amphibiens sont pas parfaites mais
là le sondage de 12 c à vous bon
dimanche au revoir